slash primary care
[Music]
former south carolina republican
congressman trey gowdy is perhaps best
known for leading a house committee that
investigated the 2012
benghazi attacks in libya attacks that
killed four americans
gowdy served four terms in congress
before announcing his decision not to
seek re-election back in 2018
and he's out now with a new book called
doesn't hurt to ask using the power of
questions
to communicate connect and persuade in
it the former prosecutor draws on the
lessons he learned in congress
and also the courtroom and trey gowdy
joins us now from greenville
south carolina mr gowdy good morning to
you
it's a very timely book sir it's a very
timely book sir
in part because it deals with
partisanship which so divides us right
now
before we get to that let's talk about
one of the sources of that partisanship
for example the events in kenosha
wisconsin the president plans to travel
there later today local officials have
said please don't come even the governor
has said please don't come
do you agree with the president's
decision to go irregardless
i do i mean i respect the fact that
people view it differently but when
you're the president you're the
president
of everyone including people who don't
like you including people who don't
vote for you um you know i get that the
governor
doesn't want the president to come but
the president actually carried wisconsin
he actually
carried the county that he's visiting
what i hope he does when he gets there
is exactly what julia jackson asked for
prayers for her son unity among people
of good conscience and then
to me most importantly answers to
legitimate questions about what happened
and what the legal consequences should
be
that's a good point there about unity uh
and answers
it brings up the question of whether you
think the president's language so far
has been focused enough on unity i'm
referring to the fact that
his supporters uh are great patriots
acting in self-defense even when they're
tied to violence even when they're
accused of murder
and and the demonstrators are aren't
peaceful protesters they're
looters or rioters or killers does the
president need to do a better job
starting today with bringing the country
together
i think we all need to be mindful of the
words that we use
you know speaker pelosi referred to
kevin mccarthy as an enemy of the state
i mean
it's fine to disagree with kevin he is
not an enemy of the state there have
been
uh other democrats who have called for
unrest in the streets i i
republican rhetoric i'm not crazy about
i i think we can all i think words
matter and we can all do
a better job of communicating the only
division i care about in this country is
not black or white or republican
democrat
people of good conscience versus people
who are not of good conscience
with respect to the shooting in
wisconsin there's a murder charge
yeah you're presumed innocent i get that
i was in the courtroom for 20 years but
there is a murder charge
we'll let a jury decide if it's
self-defense i personally would not
weigh in on that
law enforcement has charged him with
murder that's the charge that stands
yeah so it sounds like you are calling
on the president though to use more
unifying language today
in wisconsin well not just the president
i think i think
words matter i think even
a lowly member of the house when you
call for unrest in the street
and i think part of what frustrates
people is if you're going to
call out rhetoric call that out on both
sides just
don't don't just pick on one side or the
other call it out on both sides
yeah i think there's some frustration
with both sides talk
but i want to get to the book there's a
wonderful anecdote in there between you
and senator tim scott
in which senator scott asks you since
the books about questions how many times
were you pulled over last year
for tim scott it was seven for you it
was one how did that change your
thinking about racism
in the law enforcement world well
we're all prisoners of our experience
and i was a prosecutor for 20 years i've
only been stopped by the cops when i
deserve to be stopped and i've never
feared for my life so when you have tim
scott who
who may be the most decent human being
i've ever met in my life
um who looks as if he would pose a
threat to absolutely no one
and when he said i want the cops to know
that i
am not a threat to them so they're not a
threat to me
um it changed i've never been black a
day in my life i have no idea what that
feels like the only thing i can do is
borrow the eyes
of a man like tim scott and try to look
at the world through his eyes
so i can't be what i'm not but i can be
intentional about
trying to see the world through the eyes
of an african-american man
and yes it did change me but i'll say
this about tim scott
as we walk through that process you'll
never hear him refer to a routine
traffic stop anymore
because he also borrowed the eyes of
cops and what they view when they're
stopping a car or making a 9-1-1
response
i want to sneak in one more question
because it's about how the republican
party has changed and not necessarily
you changing with it
i am curious it's not the same party you
grew up with you're no longer in office
will you vote for president trump in
2020
yes all right
a good clear answer to a good clear
question trey gowdy thank